[Musique]
bon je crois que depuis quelques années
indépendamment de la structure qui
décide des commémorations on a une liste
exhaustive mais si vous regardez la
liste des années précédentes
vous vous n'aurez aucune mémoire
justement employé le terme aucune
mémoire de toutes ces commémorations qui
ont été programmés le jeu j'ai regardé
les diverses programmations you lie à la
découverte de la boxer qui à la mort de
fernandel cetc c'est une liste c'est une
liste moi je pense que multiplier les
commémorations c'est c'est détruire la
force de châteaudun mais en même temps
lille et les commémorations officielles
qui demeureront et puis il y aura cette
liste de commémoration dans lesquels
comment dire
les diverses institutions pourront
piocher si elles sont très heureuses
elles passent complètement inaperçue
d'autre part il y a lieu de voir qu'une
commémoration n'a pas forcément la même
valeur payer pour un autre il faut donc
faire très attention parce qu'une
commémoration peut être très enlevée par
un très bien vu par tano et en
définitive on ne s'y retrouve pas à
recevoir chez colas têtu de votre
existence légale truyère fils que c'est
un organisme qui n'a aucun équivalent
exactement comme plus grande indique
hélène d'honneur aucun équivalent situ
de france est en fait placé sous la
barre trop haute autorité du chef de
l'état
le bon événement en rue peel qui plaît
au public
et quels sont les goûts du public on ne
sait pas je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec mon interlocuteur plus l'événement
tiens mon papa blanc en il intéresse
s'il ya des survivants vous parliez de
la guerre d'algérie oui forcément chu 06
min
mais c'est que ça va intéresser et on
pourrait multiplier les exemples de voir
à quel point on s'imagine qu'on va
intéresser des gens et ce n'est pas que
les événements du monde entier
qu'on le veuille ou non c'est d'abord
les événements sportifs il y a deux
types de commémoration il ya des
commémorations d'événements récents pour
ne jamais dire les guerres mondiales non
plus les guerres mondiales la dernière
guerre mondiale la guerre d'algérie où
il ya encore des survivants
donc il ya une mémoire personnelle et il
y à un hommage personnel
ceux qui sont d'un des anciens
combattants ce rappel de leurs camarades
qui sont tombés et puis il ya des
commémorations qui sont plus historique
et qu'il a son consiste à mettre en
relief un événement une une découverte
et il a c'est oui on peut tomber dans
l'instrumentalisation mais c'est aussi
de la pédagogie
et un danger d'instrumenter
d'instrumentalisation dans une
commémoration mais justement la mesure
qui a été prise et elle a un double
objet elle un objet cessé de faire
sortir du domaine polémique du domaine
politique c'est à dire de la polémique
les questions de commémoration car si
c'est le gouvernement qui choisit
automatiquement il est accusé d'arrière
pensées politiques
dès lors que c'est une institut de
france il n'y a plus ce procès et il n'y
a plus non plus cette tentation
d'instrumentalisation
alors évidemment les chattes france
quelle que soit la structure qui
choisissent les commémorations elle est
formée d'hommes d'hommes qui ont des
opinions et qui à titre individuel
personnel peuvent avoir peuvent être
tentés de de l'instrumentaliser pour
payer votre expression mais au contraire
l'instrumentalisation
elle est certainement moins moindre dans
le cadre de l'institut de france qui
n'est pas du tout à la botte du poids
reçu valait tout à leur disait que à la
tête il ya le le présent à un public
dont favoriserait public c'est pas lui
qui dirige l'institut de france
la cdu 30 ce sont des académies les
élèves qu'elle ait mis son cocktail les
académiciens ne sont pas nommés par
monsieur macron ils sont nommés par les
zouaves pour les autres académiciens et
c'est cela ne garantit je connais très
très bien
le chancelier de l'institut et xavier
darcos qui est un vieil ami il était
professeur de cagnes à louis le grand
je suis d'accord mais pas totalement
parce que l'institut de france a quand
même des obligations vis-à-vis du chef
de l'état notamment le chef de l'état
peut opposer son veto à un peu près tout
mais c'est secondaire quand même
par contre ce qui est très juste de ce
qu'a dit monsieur choisey c'est que il
faut ressusciter des événements oubliés
on l'a complètement au bicentenaire de
la grippe espagnole en 1919 qui a fait
plus tôt plus de morts que la première
guerre mondiale
yann dans chaque commune française il ya
un monument ou mer aux morts de la
guerre mondiale ya jamais eu le moindre
monument à l'égard des victimes en
mémoire des victimes de cette guerre
espagnol
[Musique]